amici o un annuncio importantissimo se
mi permettete da fare questo pomeriggio
mi è arrivato un messaggio poi il solito
insomma un messaggio che mi ha fatto un
po riflettere lorini puoi salutare su un
video o su una storia mi è arrivato
questo messaggio io ho iniziato a
riflettere di ma ora facciamo una
premessa poi non avete idea da quando ho
iniziato a fare lo youtuber parlo del
2011 nuovo aperto fa vigeva e nerina del
2012 da circa quindi sei anni 67 anni
quante volte al giorno io riceva la
frase poi jaime saluti in un video voi
non avete idea di quante volte al giorno
io riceva questa frase questa credo sia
la frase che ho sentito di più in tutta
la mia vita per farvi capire quante
volte la ricevo al giorno penso sia
scontato che io non possa salutare
persone nei video perché vi svelo
l'arcano mistero che nessuno di quelli
che sta morendo questo video potrà mai
capire come o 5.070.000 iscritti al
momento in cui sto registrando questo
video immaginatevi 5.070.000 persone che
ti scrivono frigeni saluti in un video è
difficile che io riesca a sfruttare
tutte le persone non so se ve ne siete
accorti te che stai guardando costruito
in questo momento di cibo è normale che
non possa valutare tutti i tool di
fianco a te c'è una persona che non la
capisce questa cosa non ne ho idea
una persona che mischia questa cosa non
arriva con la testa a dire ma cavolo
sono loro tanti ma è che proprio forse
magari non gliela faccio questa domanda
non ci arrivo chrome e non sto parlando
dei bambini perché ovvio che questa
domanda magari dai ricevuta da un
bambino dice va bene bambino non lo
capisce no no io parlo dei ventenni
quello proprio di persone magari sono
anche più grandi di me chi mi fanno
questa domanda e mi lasciano perplesso
questo sembra sembra tra l'altro un
video di quelli tipo
ma questo è un video ricordo e quindi
non posso avuto soprattutto non me ne
frega niente di questo è solo che io nel
2009 stento a credere che riesco a
ricevere ancora queste domande da
maggiorenni e incredibile quindi ho
voluto fare un esperimento e sono fiero
di quello che ho fatto giuro ho fatto
questo esperimento
ho risposto a questa persona che mi ha
scritto certamente a che ora preferisci
cioè io mi sono messo nella testa di
questa persona che mi fa questa domanda
e le ho risposto esattamente come si
aspetta di ricevere la risposta perché
tutti quelli che mi fanno st domanda poi
si aspettano che io vi rispondo in
qualche modo noe si incazzano se non lo
faccio dico ma questo non mi ha risposto
allora si aspettano di ricevere questa
esatta risposta che io per la prima
volta in sei anni ho dato che ho scritto
quindi certamente a che ora preferisci
l'avversario in questione mi risponde
quando vuoi tu
io le rispondo alle 18 va bene o è
troppo tardi
18 perfetto quindi oggi che non è oggi
di quando è uscito il video ma quando lo
sto registrando ho pubblicato questa
storia qui sul mio profilo ho pubblicato
esattamente il saluto a questa ragazza
che si chiama eva ciao eva ti saluto in
un mio video che sono andato anche nel
video oltre che nelle storie dei rischi
perché ho salutato questa persona perché
voluto fare un esperimento sociale
mettiamola così che fosse nessuno ancora
aveva fatto che è un po strano
ho salutato questa persona non tanto per
fare ironia perché va beh io la faccio
spesso era un esperimento sociale voglio
vedere se saluto questa persona quante
persone poi nei direct lista che non mi
chiedono di essere salutate io penso che
il mio profilo lista grano in questo
giorno sia il profilo a il mondo con più
messaggi mi perdonate sono l'esca
censurare tutti ma vado veloce così non
tutti questi messaggi che vedete sono
tutte le risposte fatte ogni minuto
tutto questa cosa con scorso non sono
arrivati anche a dieci minuti di
messaggi in questione ne stanno
arrivando altri le notifiche non mi
arrivano da tutti mi arrivano solo da
pochi e non capisco il motivo
con queste sono tutte persone che mi
hanno scali ne apro una casa una casa e
poi salutare in una storia mi chiamo
nicolò che questa è un'app che ho preso
a caso ovviamente tutta gente che mi
chiede di essere salutata si tratta
anche di molti ragazzini anche di
bambini ma non solo è questo il fatto
eco ad esempio
lino vent'anni caserta taci tua che ti
segue sempre non mi cadi mai ammazzati
pubblica mi anche a me stronzo quindi
lino lino davvero scusami lino stai
tranquillo un giorno casertana napoli ci
abitiamo
non lo so parlare scusami lino scusami
li nomino scusa io mi trovo in una
condizione della mia vita in cui la
gente mi chiede di essere salutata
quindi io con tanta razionalità cerco di
fermarmi e di ragionare su dell'eroe e
dico con tutta la gente che mi chiede di
essere salutata quanto realmente la
gente mi segue vogliono avere date
quello shotout quel momento di
popolarità in modo che li vedano tutti
cercano quelli quel momento di evidenza
di mettersi in evidenza a tutti quanti
li agita di teloni e frega niente se fai
youtuber chi sei ma chicche che dicono
che istiga belle ma che me ne frega solo
che tu mi pubblichi nel tuo profilo da 3
milioni di follower perché così mi
vedono tutti e me ne vanto ragazzi
spiegatemi a cosa serve quindi io faccio
questo video semplicemente per far
vedere l'esperimento sociale che ho
fatto e a rivolgere una domanda a tutti
cioè che cosa c'è di figo nell'essere
salutati da una persona ma cosa gli
cambia dalla vita c'è una cosa che non
capisco anche non essendo conosciuto non
lo capisco tutto adesso che molte
persone mi hanno scritto anche tipo bel
gesto che hai fatto però di nota no non
lo è
quindi ragazzi ho fatto anche un cambio
di maglia probabilmente non fate domande
o anche degli occhiali non lo sto
registrando questo pezzo di video in un
altro momento per niente volevo dirvi
che è un esperimento sociale che è
successo durante la settimana ma sempre
un'altra settimana ho fatto uno dei
troni più belli della storia nella mia
storia
avete visto tutti durante la settimana
che è uscito depp trips quel gioco troll
che dura un minuto e mezzo horror dove
il finale
e questo è un troll perché uno si
aspetta di giocare un horror della
madonna e poi non lo è
quindi io l'ho consigliata un sacco di
miei amici che ci hanno giocato e
ovviamente spaccati tutti da ridere un
mio amico in particolare il signor gatto
ci ha giocato in live cioè io gli ho
detto in live lui mi fa stasera devo
fare una live mi consigli un gioco e gli
ho detto gioca a death trips e lui l'ha
giocato in live e io ho ripreso questa
cosa perché faceva lui non sapeva niente
cioè lui si è preparato una live
giocando volendo giocare a questi non
sapeva niente vi è andato in live
giocando a death trips è obbligato
questa cosa perché merita la vita vi
lascio al video perché va beh sta per
partire la sua live la sua e si chiama
serata horror mi hanno consigliato da
lui non sa cosa sta per andare a giocare
ea momenti entrerà in live noi siamo qua
per vedere la
eccolo sta entrando speriamo che non
glie lo spoiler gliel'ho consigliato io
speriamo iddio che ci caschi mentre sono
giri soldi sconsiglio fa vigili mi fa
pochi consigli un videogame ma dovrà
dare niente va bene perché ve lo
consiglio di farlo in live mi fa che ti
sei questa sì adesso non so se pareggio
sc sia sta insieme sani noti che da
questa mangia anno magari però così ho
fatto l'ho scaricato l'ho provato da
avviare per vedere se funziona ed
effettivamente funzionava un testo mi
sembra di aver capito che sia un ora io
lo spero perché c'è qualcos'altro
mi capita quando va avanti
allora io mi tolgo le cucine e mi
spoglio
vorrei chiudere la live non lo posso
fare perché ovviamente l'abbiamo avviato
vabbè
[Musica]
[Risate]
progetti gioco dell'anno geniale
continente nome inserito un povero gli
sia piaciuto consiglio è un genio
monograph al di là chiamati serviva a
darmi l'idea nei prossi mo dem oltre
[Musica]
vabbè
grazie fa vj per queste perle prego
amici
quindi ragazzi questo era il dispiacere
per il signor gatto per l'amor di dio
gli voglio bene signore però mi chiede i
giochi e io gli consiglio quando vuole
mi faccio io però che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi che sarà blog spiace aver
cambiato aver registrato due scene con
due maglie di vermi esprimo veramente
male mamma mia
non so come fate a seguirmi perché va
bene vi sia piaciuto anche un annuncio
importante da fare ha aggiunto questo
effetto sonoro al mio dalla mia
soundboard interessati
no no ma spero che la società ragazze la
gente vive felicemente mi piaceva dice
chi lo deve iniziare se non so se
rischiate e noi ci vediamo come sempre
[Musica]